It's opening
weekend for
Disney's live action
remake of The Little Mermaid,
according to Variety.
The film has already made $38 million
at the box office.
It's expected
to gross
between 120
and 130 million
over the four day Memorial Day weekend.
Now, the film,
as you may know, sparked controversy
when casting Halle
Bailey, a black woman as the new Ariel.
But how his portrayal of Ariel
has become an inspiration
for so many black
and brown girls around the world
who can finally see themselves again
once again represented on the screen.
Who could forget the heartwarming videos
from when the trailer dropped,
showing their reactions
to Bailey shooting?
I've I swam
while here
so sweet at the premiere in London.
Hell, we got to meet several fans
on the red
carpet, telling Variety
she hopes that they know they are worth
and deserve to be in these spaces.
CNN's senior entertainment reporter
Lisa France
joining us now here in studio.
Always a treat, as I like to say.
Let's talk about you know,
why representation matters
so much,
especially in this
genre of Disney princesses, right?
And what does it mean
to you to see Harley?
Yeah, I said on social media
that we talk a lot
about the representation
for young girls of color,
but for women of color, people of color.
I cried the movie meant so much to me,
especially because this country and world
feel so splintered and torn apart
right now.
So to see us up on screen in this huge
Disney production,
which is, I mean, diverse
in and of itself,
I mean, the cast,
all of our
y'all sisters
are different nationalities.
Daveed plays
the crab, you know, he's Afro-Latino.
So I feel like this film,
Disney's really gotten behind diversity.
It's the promotion for it.
I mean, the promotion budget was huge.
So for Little girls of color,
little boys of color,
grown women of color,
grown men of color,
it's just important
to have representation right now
in this era that we're living
in, we're in everything just feels like
people are so far apart.
We could all come together
and rally around this film.
Have you seen it? I have.
What do you think
So take it for what it is.
I know
a lot of people want to compare it
to the animated.
Yeah,
I feel like they did a really great job.
I feel like,
first of all,
I feel like Haley was born to play Oreo.
As soon as you hear her saying her voice.
In part of your world.
I mean, those final notes.
There's a great video of her performing
with the orchestra. I've seen that.
And when she finishes,
she kind of steps back
as if she's a little shy about it.
And all the musicians
start applauding her.
And it's just, ah,
it's just it fills your heart.
My girlfriend, Tanika,
said something to the effect
of whenever she sings, it's
like she reaches inside your chest cavity
as she hugs your heart.
And that's the best way
I've ever heard it described
How close is this live
action movie compared to the original?
So they change some things.
They change
some lyrics
to be more inclusive
and also to be less sexist.
Because they're,
you know, lots of complaints,
as some of them are older
art has not caught up
with the times that we live in now.
But I feel like
what's the most
similar in the two is just the sheer joy
that you feel from watching.
I love a musical just first of all.
So, you know,
if I could sing, I wouldn't even speak.
I'd be singing with anybody right now.
So I just feel like it's
just like the joy and the wonder of it.
I feel like we all need it,
especially right now.
If these last couple of years
that we've had,
we all need that kind of wonders.